[Music]
Jessica Biel reveals how she separates
work from home no time for it
et spoke with the 35 year old actress at
the Tribeca Film Festival where she
debuted her new TV crime thriller the
sinner you know I have never had too
much trouble letting work stay at work
and honestly as a mom you don't really
have the choice you know you have to get
home
someone needs dinner somebody's get
their pajamas on get in the bath and
then get into bed and you can't be you
know smoldering in the corner like oh
the scene I did no time for it make
dinner get him to bed Jessica also
revealed how hubby Justin Timberlake
supported her decision to take on such a
dark role he's really excited for me
he's been such a huge supporter of this
all along he knows how much the material
is interesting to me and what a great
opportunity I think this is just you
know for me to do something really
different he's really able to sort of
watch the show for what it is and not
really get too bogged down by the fact
that I you know he's seeing me in a very
different light
you